eine Drohung hat Putin in der Regel wahr
gemacht das heißt wir können jetzt
gerade nicht so blauäugig zu sein und
sagen naja der droht nur mit seinen
Nuklearwaffen er wird sie aber nie
einsetzen was machen wir eigentlich was
macht eigentlich der Westen wenn er sie
einsetzt wir dürfen uns von den Drogen
nicht einschüchtern lassen
und dann ist eben die große Kunst
die Reaktion darauf nicht einschüchtern
zu lassen
ohne gleichzeitig
irgendetwas zu tun was sich vom
vielleicht im Sinne einer Eskalation
vermeiden lese ist das nur rote Linie ab
der wir uns dann fundamental anders
verhalten müssen gegenüber Putin gegen
Russland ja klar aber dann ist der
nächste Schritt wenn man einmal nachgibt
gibt man immer nach deswegen war ja
immer klar dass man eben sich nicht
erpressen lassen darf wer einer
Erpressung einmal nachgibt wird immer
weiter erpresst da habe ich auch meine
viel bescheideneren Erfahrungen in
diesen 50 Jahren immer wieder mal
gemacht und ich bin eigentlich gut damit
gefahren zu sagen nein
ich lasse mich nicht erpressen wir haben
ja doch eine Situation in der Putin
einsehen muss wahrscheinlich ist halt
schmerzlicher
Prozess der einzig dass seine Armee auch
nicht annähernd so leistungsfähig ist
wie er das wohl gedacht hat er hat sich
ja wahrscheinlich im Februar vorgestellt
dass er fürchten muss ein
konventionellen Krieg gegen die Ukraine
verlieren zu können Mensch vorstellen
können und
jetzt ist es gar nicht mehr so
unrealistisch die kritisieren auch die
Bürger die sich versorgen lassen wollen
von dem Staat die sozusagen nur
Erwartungen haben und das finde ich
völlig in Ordnung und ich meine das
Entscheidende ist dass die Menschen das
Gefühl haben müssen es geht fair zu es
wird den geholfen die es wirklich
brauchen man muss den Menschen schon
sagen ja das wird schwierig und dann
muss man eben sagen was geht und was man
kann den Menschen nicht ersparen dass
die Energie sehr viel teurer wird aber
man kann natürlich sagen gut die die das
nicht mehr schaffen können
den wird geholfen wir empfinden sie das
nach all den Jahrzehnten Wohlstand dass
wir über Blackouts sprechen und über
kalte Wohnungen das ist nicht
selbstverständlich es ist doch gut und
dann sieht man halt ein Pullover an und
wenn man einen zweiten Pullover anzieht
dann geht es auch wir hatten übrigens
schon mal in den 70er Jahren
Helmut Schmidt war Bundeskanzler hatten
wir ja auch eine Energiekrise da ist
auch schon damals in öffentlichen
Gebäuden ich glaube die Raumtemperaturen
Washington ist damals auf 17 Grad
festgelegt worden und die mussten auch
der amerikanische Präsident hat
jedenfalls symbolisch ein Pullunder
angezogen Strom ist nicht mehr
selbstverständlich das Licht Schrauben
ist schon selbstverständlich aber es
kann auch mal ausfallen ja deswegen hat
man den Zweifel auch ein paar Kerzen und
ein paar Streichhölzer zu Hause und dann
ist natürlich wichtig dass man weiß wo
die sind falls es mal dunkel wird im
Dunkeln suchen ist auch schwierig wenn
man glauben
der Staat sei nur noch was was seinen
Bürgern alles mögliche liefern müssen
also so eine Art Supermarkt wo man
Schnäppchenjäger macht oder der Staat
muss jetzt nie von dem wollte ich muss
Angeboten machen bessere Angebote und so
nein wenn ich ihn Umfragen
lese
dass viele Menschen lieber weniger
arbeiten würden
ich finde weniger aber nicht auch schön
aber auch nicht unser dringend das
Bedürfnis und ein erfülltes Leben nicht
ganz sicherlich eines indem man nur Spaß
hat man muss darauf setzen dass man nur
den hilft die es wirklich brauchen und
den anderen muss man sagen tut mir leid
ja ich verstehe gut dass du nicht mehr
dafür bezahlen möchtest
aber zur Not kannst du jetzt mal eine
Urlaubsreise nicht machen
oder vielleicht musste zur Not hier in
Deutschland irgendwo Urlaub machen und
kannst nicht auf die
Galapagos Inseln oder was der Kuckuck
wohin ich möchte noch eine Frage stellen
die ich vor zwei Wochen im Friedrich
Merz gestellt habe habe ich gefragt ob
wir in diesen Krisenzeiten wo wir nicht
nur corona-krise haben sondern jetzt
eben vor allen Dingen Tiefe Energiekrise
und man in solchen Zeiten wo man den
Menschen so viel zumutet beispielsweise
eine restriktive Flüchtlingspolitik
braucht weil sich Menschen schneller
überfordert fühlen ich war immer dafür
dass wir eine Migrationspolitik
betreiben wo mir den Ärmsten der Armen
im Rahmen unserer Möglichkeiten so gut
wie möglich helfen
aber nicht indem sie alle nach Europa
kommen aber Sie müssen menschenwürdig
behandelt werden denn das ist nun ein
Prinzip Europas gewesen aber wenn wir
sagen jetzt
haben wir es nicht mehr so gut jetzt
können wir auch nichts geben schauen Sie
ich kann mich an die Jahre
die ersten Jahre nach dem Krieg schon
insofern erinnern Flüchtlinge waren auch
bei uns
damals nicht angesehen im in der
Kleinstadt im Schwarzwald wo ich gelebt
habe aber Flüchtlinge waren ja nicht
irgendwelche Menschen aus fernen
Kontinenten sondern das waren Menschen
aus östlichen Teilen Deutschlands
gewesen oder die eben irgendwo ihre
Heimat verloren hatten und den hat man
natürlich nicht gerne vielleicht
manchmal aber man hatte ihn geholfen und
darin zeigt sich ja die Menschlichkeit
einer Gesellschaft dass sie egal wie es
Ihnen geht wie schlecht du das Gute
hingeht dem dem schlechter geht helfen
wenn sie können also hat Friedrich Merz
schon einen Punkt ohne dieses Wort
sozialtourismus wenn er von diesem
pull-faktoren spricht dass wir schon
gucken müssen wie groß die Anreize sind
die wir setzen Herr Friedrich Merz hat
darauf hingewiesen und der Adria da hat
er ja völlig recht das Problem der
Migration auf dieser Erde was ja durch
Krieg durch Hunger durch durch
ökologische Probleme dramatisch noch
verschärft werden wird
das ist nicht dadurch zu lösen dass alle
Menschen den schlecht geht nach Europa
kommen oder dahin wo es den Menschen
noch nicht schlecht geht und deswegen
muss man eine
verantwortliche Migrationspolitik
betreiben die darf aber nicht aber das
hat ja auch nicht gesagt kann unser
Gegenteil aber so ist es manchmal mit
der Kommunikation mit den falschen
Begriff gebrauchst dann kriegst du das
nicht richtig wieder los das ist nicht
einfach aber gesagt hat er ganz klar wir
müssen eine verantwortliche
Migrationspolitik betreiben gerade damit
wir den schwächsten auf dieser Welt im
Rahmen dessen was wir überhaupt leisten
können auch leisten
auch hilfeleisten gibt es in diesen
schweren Krisenzeiten wo man wenn man
über das Weltgeschehen nachdenkt
eigentlich nur deprimiert sein kann gibt
es Dinge über die Sie richtig lachen
können es gibt ein schönes evangelisches
Kirchenlied ergibt sich Strophe wir
machen unser Schmerz und Leid nur größer
durch die Traurigkeit der amerikanische
Botschafter der zurzeit der
Wiedervereinigung des Mauerfalls in Bonn
gewesen ist hat die Geschichte erzählt
er hat einen hohen amerikanischen
Offizier
1945 bei einer Fahrt durch eine der
zerstörten Städte in im Ruhrgebiet
begleitet
und dann stand in einer so einer Höhle
also so ein Fenster was nicht mehr war
in so einer Ruine eine Blechdose mit ein
paar Blumen drin und dann hat er
Offizier zu den Burner Walter seinem
Assistenten gesagt
schauen Sie sich das an dieses Volk wird
nicht untergehen wenn Menschen in einer
solchen Situation Blumen in eine
Blechdose ins Fenster stellen die werden
nicht untergehen und das darin steckt
die Wahrheit wir haben keinen Grund zu
resignieren
wir müssen tun was immer wir tun können
und wir wissen wissen dass es das wert
ist
und dann können wir uns darüber freuen
also nochmal heute ist blauer Himmel die
Sonne scheint ja worüber wollen sie sich
nicht freuen
danke sehr Herr Schäuble für das
Gespräch